the DI heart languages with dying
I wondered what else was being killed
millions of wards mutilated thousands of
songs unsung hundreds of stories untold
which language I pondered who answered
this how long will it take for humanity
to be human the day I heard
languages were dying I didn't feel so
alive myself yeah now you slide out okay
more and more information is being made
available on the web so our goal really
has been to develop microsoft translator
hub in such a way that it would be web
accessible from anywhere in the world
this empowers communities and
organizations that want to build custom
translation models to really take
control of it to create improve even
deploy the system without a translator
service getting in the way
now this sense of empowerment allows
under-resourced communities in
particular to preserve their language
and their community and culture for
generations to come
so as Microsoft looks to provide support
and services to governments and
countries all over the world we have to
embrace and respect the local
communities to create cultural
opportunities economic opportunities and
opportunities for individuals to
communicate within their communities and
communities all over the world in their
language with their culture and history
preserved and Microsoft translator hub
enables that opportunity for governments
for communities and for citizens all
over the world what we did is we ran a
couple of workshops and we did this in
order to reach out specifically to
language communities one of them was
with the Hmong in Fresno and the other
one was actually at Kathmandu University
with the Nepali language the Nepalese
students that we interacted with it
Katmandu well many of them weren't even
fluent in their own language which was
very surprising to discover that they
were more fluent in English than they
were in their own native language
I personally don't speak in Nepali
fluently and the project Microsoft
translator hub is helping me improve my
fluency and I think it will also help in
preserving the Nepali language the
elders inside of the Hmong community
we're watching their culture slip away
one elder at a time if we don't do
anything about it the culture and the
language of the moment is going to
disappear in this country but with
projects such as this it's going to be
one of the very important step that we
can take to stop this from happening
the project is very important among
first of all well there are many reasons
one of them of course that comes to mind
is that the language itself the written
language itself is less than sixty years
old so that makes it very difficult for
for the Hmong people to actually
preserve any type of culture or any type
of a written language so the project not
only allows the non speakers of English
to be where access information that are
in English but also allows them the
speakers to now network across countries
this machine translation project which
will work on the nepali english spear
will help us share our culture local
tradition and rituals to the rest of the
world how do we do more preserve more
languages and more cultures as we go
forward
today it's Napoli and mom tomorrow it's
the world
you